oh hey guys didn't see you there if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real region um hey guys
I'm Ryan right like memento we start at
the end yeah hey I'm Jerry this is Jerry
so we're gonna do the phase two of
honest trailers in honor of Avengers age
of Ultron why talk anymore let's get to
it with Iron Man a threat I really dug
this moment
second time I like them when a terrorist
mastermind kidnaps the president now
country to it these there's only one
Marvel franchise that Disney can afford
to call
I wish nope just this guy no really just
a guy not even the suit Tony Stark is
regular man is Iron Man 3 prepare for an
Iron Man movie with hardly any Iron Men
in it and no a CDs either suit up with
billionaire Tony Stark as he doesn't
suit up in a summer blockbuster that for
no reason at all takes place on
Christmas and see him like you never
wanted to see hippy shame like moon is a
human's course I can harness anxious
check the heart chicken connects the
brain Hey paralyzed
with regular man sidelined by the
whispers of children kids up to his
latest creation to save the day
remote control man this is a new level
of flame you've seen the Iron Man armor
hold its own against Thor the God of
Thunder
now after dozens of upgrades it runs out
of batteries time eight to sleep out
constantly malfunctions falls apart
falls apart again
Manitou falls apart again yeah falls
apart again
yeah and takes its sweet time to
assemble that five four three come on
two five seriously the Avengers are
simple faster than this but remote
control man's not alone Tony spent his
downtime building all kinds of robots
that break faster than bad cosplay like
forearms man choking hazard man and
cranes steadying juggernaut man Tony and
his rapping suits must pull together to
face his greatest foe since alcoholism
the Mandarin universe in a timely update
of the character Osama bin Kingsley
plays the brilliant terrorist who
manipulates the entire country into
doing his bidding
my name is Trevor Trevor stock trader
wait what octo meandering seas nori no
you can't do that you can they were
doing such a good job and they turn him
into a punchline this is our man's
arch-nemesis this isn't just ignore in
the comics this is dropping their pants
and wiping their butt with them when bad
guys do they even replace him with I am
the manta ray all come on instead we get
Aldrich Killian and X nerd out revenge
after Tony's gift a meeting one time the
firepower getting hot sex potent super
strength
free growing lives flameproof clothes
and shooting fire out of their mouths
they really just made it up as they went
along huh witness the least thought-out
sequence of the Iron Man trilogy as Tony
Stark gives his personal address to a
terrorist 10 eight eighty Mountain then
goes home and puts on his only
unfinished Iron Man suit let someone
walk through his front door doesn't see
the missile heading for his house until
it's on the news still doesn't activate
any kind of home security system or any
of the 40 other remote controlled Iron
Man suits in his basement or have Jarvis
call the police or shield or an Avenger
so you tell me Nick Fury shows up for
coffee and doughnuts but not when Tony
Stark might be dead so watch as the Iron
Man trilogy ends with ten of the
franchise's most disappointing minutes
we're killing the
with Paltrow in yoga pants all the Iron
Man suits get blown up for no reason and
Tony has the operation that will make
him regular man forever
at least until Avengers 2 starring
Archer detail Cooper hero Gandhi nerds
memento Murtagh
Vincent Baker ha ha worst extra ever is
something gonna kill this guy
just saying I'm not sorry the whole Thor
Captain America Nick Fury right Widow
Hawkeye Agent Coulson you can bully a
hill Sylve or even the Galaga
I have a free so you heard no no I'm not
that kind of doctor dude where were you
the whole movie hey screen junkies what
I don't agree with a lot of that okay I
agree with all of that the first time I
watched it okay the second time I
watched it about a week ago I was like
this is a great film is it really I
think it's fantastic because there was
Tony start in the first Iron Man and
then in Iron Man 2 it was like a lot of
Iron Man stuff but then part three you
know like I think about that question
and the Avengers at cap asks him the
clump cap is on like best friends cuz we
uh that hang out Captain America asked
him what he says without the suit would
argue and I think an Iron Man 3 he
really proves that and I would have a
prom with the suits falling apart either
he has PTSD but he does so much as
regular man and he becomes efficient you
know so I like how he had to like lose
the super rebuild so much stuff and I
thought it was cool when he broke it you
like the mandarins helmet stuff yeah I
like that and their complaints are
usually about like there's not enough
Iron Man I'm usually like yeah no more
Tony yeah you know I like that stuff and
I I'm in the minority but I like the
Mandarin twist I thought that was good
the first time I saw a Mandarin to us
you know how much I hated it yeah the
second time I watched it like just
because I started from phase 1 and then
got to they're just ignoring all comic
books and just taking it for what it is
I like it it's a total twist I could get
how from the comic book perspective yeah
it's [ __ ] up it's a total [ __ ]
twist and you don't see it coming
you'll never see me coming
oh I saw for the first time yesterday
Marvel one-shot all hail the king it's a
Trevor in prison
it's brilliant it makes you think like
wait a minute this guy it's about him in
prison after he's been captured this is
look at future Enders it's a short film
starring Ben Kingsley you see that maybe
this guy is actually the Mandarin but
he's kind of lost his mind
like maybe he doesn't remember just what
he's done maybe he's just a bunch of
split personalities that's a can of
worms it's a it is a can of worms iron
man's like addicted to the seats in this
movie it's it's a distraction
yeah he's shooting the shoots into it
literally at the beginning it's shooting
a microchip it's goes up so when he lets
go the suits and he destroys all them
he's saying like I'm ready to let go now
move on be a man again and like he gets
rid of the chestplate thing so he can so
he's learning not to be dependent
anymore on these things so I actually
respect the ending and I thought it was
cool like Gweneth Paltrow had a chance
to like kick some ass in the end so and
it's funny too it's a really funny movie
and well it's like funny ball so darker
then yeah and I like seeing Tony go
through those stresses because it made
sense and at the same time it made it
more relatable yeah I didn't feel so
distant from Tony in this one yeah yeah
you know I totally feel like he
understands me
I felt really connected to Tony
completely mine is pure intellect and
skills for technology but there's one
thing I learned about Robert Downey jr.
don't ask him about his personal life
okay next one Thor the dark world
what shorter honest trailer yo I invite
you into my home you just got to keep
your mouth shut when you're here
nice alright yeah see Thor the film that
tided bans over until the Avengers Wow
experience the film that will tie fans
over until the Avengers to Thor the dark
world I really like this before is back
in another perfectly adequate Marvel
movie that pleasantly killed a few hours
of your time with enough cool visuals
action and humor to keep you from
wondering why does the Elfman want to
shoot magic kool-aid into the sky holes
return for another post Avengers movie
full of references to the Avengers your
New York after New York but no actual
adventures
instead of Earth's Mightiest Heroes
watch the watch in love once again with
Heimdall don't watch both Guardian you
can see everything
Idris Elba's by and to his girlfriend
consejo and this gigantic spaceship
directly above it and the first line is
between who are so replaceable they
switched out one of the actors and you
totally didn't notice oh and Eric's
favorite Loki
the charismatic trickster who no one
should trust by now he's still that
trust me brother how would you know
idiot when he's not battling yet another
forgettable bad guy watch as the Mighty
Thor mopes around Asgard in a Snuggie
because he still hung up on a girl he
spent one long weekend with and hasn't
called in two years where were you
Natalie Portman returns as Jean Grey
from the x-men Phoenix saga with the
help of her wacky sidekick her other
Becky's archaic and her other wacky
sidekicks wacky psychic they'll discover
the convergence of piece of science
mumbo-jumbo why everybody keeps trying
to eat
once a cycle all the world's align the
alignment is only temporary you must be
in exactly the right place than that
time because it's is gonna go ballistic
increases and decreases and gravity
spatial extrusions whatever can we just
see the work hit something with a hammer
again thank you travel across the nine
realms ranging from birth to vanaheim to
spuds but I am yes good as good home of
the most venerable impenetrable city
ever
so right of all with a god of thunder
y'all not God so right along with the
guy of thunder for another celebration
of the male form in all its beauty
featuring as Jewish and pixelated bugs
and starring Gail's brother
Natalie poured woman for loki goldeneye
the Nutty Professor and Oscar Ken
Jennings Stanley and we've gotten back
to lack the dark world now you're
thinking like quiet on that page that
was funny that was funny they don't
really dog the movie that much I really
like Thor the dark world a lot he had a
good time there watching porn over there
I really seriously yeah
I wasn't lying for nah um just I kind of
want to be there actually um listen I'll
do the rest of these so with Thor the
dark world I love that yeah it honors
that title it's much darker I think it
was shot better in my opinion I know you
really liked those shots i kenneth
branagh likes to do well like this do
they call it Dutch angles yeah but in
Thor the dark world I love the
cinematography I thought the shows were
better the word actually has his powers
for most of the movie what is more is
even more down that fantasy hole you
know I thought tour that production
design and it's more of that you know
swords and shields and all sorts I like
that like how it's a mixture of like
it's like you feel a lot of Star Wars
tribute in there it's like pure sci-fi
fantasy well and even elements like Lord
of the Rings know that you know like I
think more of actually of Lord of the
Rings as I do with Star Wars when I
watch this I like also this that was my
favorite performance of Loki yeah that
of like the three Loki roles we've got
and that was my favorite one because in
these movie in the Thor movies he gets
to be more of a character character yeah
you get a little more exploration mmm
and I thought they made Natalie Portman
a little more interesting
but I love what I really I got to say I
really hate that moment when she travels
through the the
portal and becomes wacky character
inexplicably for like 10 minutes
sometimes her comedy felt a little
forced especially in that moment yeah
he's like let's do that again I'm like
but I like the it's not your character
though but the I thought the action was
great Marvel's known to not really do
great with her villains but I like the
villain in this one well I like all
their villains it's just that not all of
them are scary or like truly formidable
you don't want to remember them that
much but I really like Chris Eccleston
like you know I thought I did a good job
it is it's in the writing it's hard to
make a villain truly scary when we know
that for our hero gonna be here next
time because our entire money-making
system rides on that I do really like
what they did with one of the wacky
sidekicks um who's the scientist guy
again the doctor Oh stellan skarsgård
yeah I like how they changed his
character in this cuz in the first one
he's like very serious you know the one
who's supposed to doubt all in the
Avengers you know he was me mind warped
but then in this one they're taking that
and they made him like a genius crazy
guy yeah and it was so much more fun to
watch more distinguished yeah I really
enjoyed him in that and you don't really
see him go all out with comedy yeah he's
usually some creepy dude or serious just
a serious yeah yeah we're talking about
fishing and nymphomaniac all right let's
move on to the next one next one's our
Captain America Winter Soldier and
guardians we're not really gonna talk
too much about these because we already
have like spoiler reviews up for them
and I already have like my own solo
reviews up for guardians and Winter
Soldier I know my opinions haven't
changed so if you want to know what we
have to say about it just go check those
videos out yeah but I do want to see the
honest trailers for them
you
were that impressed with his first movie
he wasn't your favorite Avenger now get
ready for the sequel that made everyone
say holy [ __ ] who knew Captain America
kicked so much ass Captain America the
Winter Soldier
the captain is back and he didn't skip
leg day come on you expert martial
artist real as he did uses lame Avenger
suit for cool new one yeah thumbs up the
full range of his vaguely defined
superpowers like super gymnastic certain
were throwing super catching and super
jumping out of stuff
he weird a person when he's not kicking
ass or taking names vocab as he spends
his free time freaking out kids of
museums hanging with his Gill and
catching up in the last 60 years of pop
culture I'll put it on the list
man stars must have blown his mind ah
when Hydra returns cab needs to take him
out by forming a team he can trust
including Black Widow a sneaky double
agent we really shouldn't trust and
Falcon a random guy he met on the street
Tamara steer Isaac watch his cab and two
non superheroes end up actually taking a
lot of ass together a really
entertaining well directed movie uh-huh
we have to be honest it's good but since
honest trailers is a comedy series get
ready for nitpicky cuffs not shocking
revelation that Hydra has been secretly
growing inside of shield on a long
despite the fact that the previous
Marvel movies really didn't do anything
to set that up and get ready to try to
ignore questions like what did they fury
stop wearing the bulletproof vest that
st. is like native injuries why didn't
Oni store find out about Hydra we
decrypted all of shields files and if
you are zoned up every dirty secret
Shield is how to try to hide out at an
agency that employs thousands of people
hide the fact that half of its agents
were members of a secret Nazi death cult
for over 60 years if she'll had their
hands on the tesseract for so long
why didn't Hydra just use that to take
over the world
then was the red skulls plan the first
place right and he was the og Hydra and
if Nick Fury was such a threat why
didn't hide her try to kill him before
he saved Tony Stark's life thought out
their greatest enemy and assembled a
team of superheroes that would almost
certainly stop any legal plans they had
for the future see we told you it'd be
nitpicking so sit back and enjoy the
best standalone Marvel movie since hire
man full of awesome action awesome
cameos and one awesome twist they run
into the ground where Bucky turns out to
still be alive and dr. Zola turns out to
still be alive and Nick Fury turns out
to still be alive and crossbone turns
out it okay no one ever really dies it's
movie still great though story American
Austin Powers mad-eye moody on frozen
caveman soldier Lucy
Falcon punch Robert red Toyota and a
hard drive Captain America he's cool now
so camp it's the safety of the free
world on two people not wanting to buy
gum not very plain mad be shorted pretty
sweet very uh yeah I'm really glad I
didn't bag on it let's move on to
guardians of jolly yeah I want to go
back everyone's oh alright last one or
phase two and then get ready for The
Avengers age of Ultron review I promise
that we'll never shoot another
ah okay okay we got it keep your star
pads on
without the rights to some of its most
popular titles and its biggest stars
contracts about to expire
watch Marvel Studios scrape the bottom
of the barrel for their obscure
seventies comic book and barely anyone
read proving once and for all will see
anything if you slap Marvel's name in
front of it
guardians of the galaxy Suda for
Marvel's attempted Star Wars in a
science fantasy adventure about heroes
you've never heard of Starling who
protecting a planet none of them live on
from an underdeveloped alien villain
whose problems you couldn't care less
about we're really region aired this was
a fun movie journey across the desert to
meet this gang of lovable misfits
there's Captain Star the ward from
America the human leader from a
different time in place like Captain
America Gamora the Black Widow ish
leather-clad female assassin like Black
Widow Drax the guy with the killer abs
who doesn't understand our customs in a
Thor kind of way Groot a big hulking
tree get it and rock it the wisecracking
tech genius with a drinking problem like
Tony's hahahahaha say there the space
Avengers but I guess it's technically
not stealing at the ripping all
themselves watch the Guardians race to
find an excuse for more Avenger sequels
by chasing after the Infinity stone and
orb of world conquering power that no
one bothers to guard and a gem so
powerful it can kill you just by
touching it unless you're this guy or
you can join hands to disperse its power
unless you're these guys or you can just
jam it into a hammer and use it safely
from there it's best not to think about
it too hard you thought the Avengers was
nerdy you ain't seen nothing yet between
all the action and comedy get ready for
a whole lot of space mumbo-jumbo
I will look for 1,000 years of Kree
justice on Xandar what's important now
is we get the Ravagers army
help us sings and all so we can give the
stone to yondu the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
Phoenix there as you can figure any of
that out try to figure out why this blue
alien isn't working with this blue alien
who's working for this blue alien to
kill this regalian who both want to kill
this purple alien as dustless christmas
coloured alien but if you can confuse
just remember the hero is still the
white guy so experience the swagger of a
movie studio drunk on its own power as
marvel trolls the world with balls-out
little fingers to the audience they know
they have in the palm of their hands oh
you like superheroes well how about a
movie that stars a king raccoon enough
intrigue you like Vin Diesel yeah well
we cast and Neal he says one king wide
that's cool you want more petty greed
actors will put them in stupid outfits
and make up a safe space for all Nova
pilots interlock and form a blockade
because who doesn't want to be in a
Marvel movie
hey recognize that chubby idiot from
Parks and Rec we're gonna turn him into
a sex symbol that would be hilarious
remember the worst movie ever made
Howard the Duck stick that after the
credits when everyone's expecting
Avengers 2 it'll totally put our band
and they'll love it anyways speaking of
way to remember that us from that one
scene at the end
here's a few years ago well we're
bringing him back and he's still not do
it why because you we're barble that's
why what are you gonna do watch TC
thought so
starring Marvel Chris number three
marina teary Drax on tracks off cheap
Barca cocoon Blue Man Group dr. steve
brule and dark side
Marvel space Avengers okay I get where
star-lords Walkman came from but we
didn't get a tape deck for a spaceship
galaxy Shack hi sure to subscribe for
more honest trailer well oh that's the
adventure alright guys well that's it
for today if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can follow Gerry on this channel
two reasons to Gerry and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement
there's so much I would like to be
sponsored by pornhub.com xvideos com
I don't think the bed to get product
play you born let's say send you like a
t-shirt um
midgets evil what products they make
besides like streaming porn videos that
they didn't make in the first place
dildo companies but then it wouldn't be
through porn her breast enhancement
company he's gonna fleshlight tuck in
jobs it's just something you do yourself
yeah that's kind of like a hand and legs
want to promote evening a lot I want to
be able to post Instagram photos of
tugging jobs will do it you have all the
means right here follows